This episode is brought to you by Ridge wallet.
What's up guys, Jared here,
if you've checked Twitter or turned on the news recently,
you might've noticed a theme.
We are seeing president Trump's odds of reelection,
starting to dwindle quite significantly. And this'll be over by,
by January one way or the other.
So from the consumer side, very, very strong. And that's really a driver of, uh,
of, of the overall profit economic forecast.
How far will COVID spread? Who's going to win the election.
When will the economy crash?
There's no shortage of people who claim to have hacked the future in the
seventies.
People claim they could predict the stock market based on who won the super
bowl. And you don't need to think that far back to remember this.
Republicans are not going to win this next election or this that the Corona
virus will follow the same path and go away with the arrival of warmer weather
in the summer, or who.
Can forget Jim Cramer with this doozy.
Should I be worried about barristers in terms of liquidity and get my money out
there? No, no, no.
Right before 2008 financial crash.
It was the worst day on wall street. Since the crash of 1987.
Surrounded by very bad predictions, whether they're from your uncle teachers,
news, personalities, even people with fancy degrees.
So what can you do to not fall for the snake oil of charming political punditry
and who can you believe welcome to this wisecrack edition on predictions?
What do they know? Do they know things let's find out, but before we continue,
I want to give a shout out to our sponsors over at Ridge.
The Ridge is a light and sleek wallet that is designed to help you get rid of
your old lumpy leather wallet.
The Ridge wallet is the last wallet you may ever need.
Since each one is made from extremely durable materials like carbon fiber, Burt,
titanium, and aluminum. In fact,
they're so durable that each wallet comes with a lifetime warranty.
It holds up to 12 cards and still has room for cash.
And the best part is that it's made with RFID blocking technology.
So you're protected from digital pickpockets. I love that.
It's just so slim and I don't have to go out with awkward dad pockets.
Every time I want to go to the store, it also looks really stylish.
You can get your own wallet and over 30 different colors and styles. Right now,
you can get your own Ridge wallet for 10% off by going to
ridge.com/wisecrack and using the code wisecrack at checkout.
And now back to the show, let me start by introducing you to Philip Tetlock,
a psychologist who has spent much of his career studying political forecasting.
Over 20 years, he tracked 80,000 predictions made by almost 300 people.
All of whom made a living,
offering insights into the future of politics and the economy.
And what he found was well, pretty terrible.
Ted luck measured the predictions that could be put on some kind of scale,
like will there be more of something less of something or will it stay the same?
Today's version of these predictions might sound like will the war in Syria get
better worsen or stay the same one might also predictive support for Donald
Trump or Joe Biden. Respectively will increase decrease Oregon stay the same.
You might expect someone with a political science background to Excel here,
armed with facts. They could confidently forecast.
What's going to happen in Syria. I, on the other hand might wildly guess a,
B or C, but here's the thing. According to Tetlock,
I'd probably beat most of the experts. That's right.
Tetlock's professional predictors of the world were generally less accurate than
random chance or monkeys throwing darts or Jared Bauer wildly guessing on a
history exam. However you want to think about it. So screw the experts.
Well,
not quite Tetlock is quick to point out that while people have taken his study
to mean that there are no trustworthy experts. That's not the case.
They're just a small minority, but it gets worse.
Tetlock found one specific kind of expert among his study. The bold predictors,
people who have a theory of how the world works are completely sure of that
theory and make daring big predictions. Tetlock calls these people hedgehogs,
and to put it bluntly. They're the worst.
I want nachos and Buffalo wings. Oh, and guac.
And where it isn't,
it let's look at political commentator and famous hedgehog bill.
Kristol a man who makes his living writing and talking about the news.
He predicted Iraq would be a two-month war.
From his is going to be a two on four. And.
That Barack Obama would not win a single primary over Hillary Clinton on 2015
amidst the Republican campaigns.
He had proclaimed peak Trump no less than 11 times. And bill crystal,
despite all of this has a thriving career on cable news.
Crystal's bad predictions. Aren't an ideological issue.
Tetlock found bold predicting hedgehogs equally on the left and the right,
but get ready. A storm is coming.
So they tended towards the more extreme ends of each spectrum.
And it's not just that crystal and people like him are dumb dumbs on TV who
don't know anything Tetlock found as a hedgehog's knowledge increases about a
specific topic, their prediction, accuracy worsens. From here,
we can immediately understand the problem about some of the bolder COVID
predictions that it would definitely fizzle out by April.
And that outbreak will reach its highest point. In the second week of April.
That hydroxy chloroquine was a wonder drug before we all had the data,
very powerful drug.
These so-called experts stand in stark contrast to the people we should actually
be listening to 10 Luxe.
Other kind of expert is a lot less interesting to listen to than hedgehogs like
Jim Cramer or bill crystal Tetlock calls them foxes.
They were experts who had hem and haw about the future.
Considering a wide variety of data points and perspectives.
Blueberry muffin for ya. Uh, I don't know, baby.
I can't decide you're right there, mate. Okay. I've made my decision.
I want to start currently.
Not exactly crystal balls,
but they have a better track record than the hedgehogs. Unlike hedgehogs,
they become more accurate as the accumulate more knowledge,
but most of the time foxes don't exactly make for entertaining cable news
guests.
After all what's more fun and expert predicting a landslide election that will
forever change the nation or someone who likes to dive into the countless
variables and uncertainty before just shrugging their shoulders and declaring
that there's not enough data, but what about COVID predictions?
I'm not talking about pundits on CNN. I'm talking about the scientist.
It seems that even listening to them,
they're always changing their minds about how many people will get sick or die,
or these just talking heads,
making big bold predictions with absolutely no scrutiny.
Not quite obviously holding people accountable for they were wrong about is fine
and good, but to understand why COVID predictions are always changing.
And for good reason, I want to talk about.
48 Degrees in the upper Northwest and 38 degrees in the middle
East. We're actually.
Very good at predicting the weather.
So let's talk about it with a little bit of a dumbed down model. Generally,
if there's a 90% chance of rain for a specific area,
it will rain nine times out of 10 and won't rain one out of 10 times.
And because meteorologists are constantly making predictions,
we can scrutinize their track record and they can improve upon it.
Things get more complicated when you forecast for large areas,
like when part of a city has a 100% chance of rain and the other half has a 40%
chance. These probabilities will often get mushed together. But again,
we're working with the very basic unit of forecasting.
The important thing for weather predicting is that it relies on a model of how
the weather works. A model is like your kindergarten arts and crafts project,
a smaller,
more manageable representation of a much bigger and complicated reality.
In the case of a meteorologist their model might include wind patterns and
pressure fronts,
and how these interact to figure out how likely it is that a storm system will
ruin my dog pageant, importantly,
weather models and all models rely on assumptions models,
make assumptions about which variables matter and prioritize them over others to
figure out a very specific outcome. Weather predictions, assume for instance,
that YouTube trending videos won't influence a Stormfront and for good reason,
COVID models do the same. For example,
they might be less interested in the variable,
how many wisecracks subscribers a state has and more interested in the
percentage of people who are social distancing,
predicting rain is a yes or no outcome that could be given a specific
probability. However,
when it comes to COVID where the total number of cases can be anywhere from zero
to approximately 8 billion,
it's a little less helpful and a lot harder to say there is a 1 billion of a
percent chance that exactly 37 people will get infected. Instead,
epidemiologists use confidence intervals,
which is a fancy way of saying I'm 95% confident.
The amount of new cases will be between this number and that number,
but like the weather.
There's also the understanding that the real number could fall outside.
That range 5% of the time. And importantly,
that number range rests on a lot of assumptions.
Assumptions about how infectious, the diseases, the percentage of infections,
mask usage could decrease. How many States will enter lockdown?
How well will they enforce it?
Will people in Florida start having COVID parties to spread the disease.
Unsurprisingly, getting every assumption, right, is a pre Herculean task,
especially when talking about finicky humans as statistician George E-box
writes, all models are wrong.
The practical question is how wrong do they have to be to not be useful.
And unlike our weather system,
disease outbreaks involve people who can be influenced by your prediction and
completely upend your assumptions. If your model says,
this will all be over next week with the assumption that everyone will stay in
doors,
my friends and I might declare an early victory and resume our normal practice
of licking. The fresh produce at whole foods. Don't do this. You know,
something that undermines the models, assumptions, hypothetical society.
One example of assumptions gone wrong can be seen in the much reported
prediction in April that Corona virus deaths would virtually stop in the summer.
This model put out by the Institute for health metrics and evaluation made one
assumption that was lambasted by other public health experts that the United
States curve of cases would resemble that of countries like China and Italy.
In some ways,
this is exactly what modeling is about condensing the complicated information
into a graspable proxy,
but it also rests on the assumption that the state and federal governments would
act in a comparable way to other governments that people would wear masks in a
similar fashion, et cetera.
And as you may have guessed America doesn't act like other countries.
I don't mean to compare the I M H E here to hedgehogs on the news though,
making wrong assumptions. Shouldn't cast someone into prediction hell,
unless they do so time after time without ever pausing for reflection.
Unfortunately, this is what some media outlets will have.
You believe that changing a prediction is a sign of an intellectual failure.
For instance,
a model from Imperial college London projected that without drastic
interventions, more than half a million Britains would die from COVID-19 later,
the scientists who led the modeling team said he expected deaths in the UK to
top out at 20,000.
The talent is,
would be probably unlikely to exceed about 20,000 with a effective
devil.
This caused one reporter to call it a remarkable turn on Twitter.
While the daily mail ran a story on the scientist patchy record and the
Federalists declared that he just walked back the apocalyptic prediction.
But of course there was no changing course as the Imperial college model
predicted multiple outcomes based on different assumptions. In this case,
the scary number was always the government does nothing assumption in the 20,000
dead was under the drastic government intervention assumption. And of course,
any models Imperial college or otherwise should change their estimates as more
data pours in about transmission rate of the disease about if reinfection as
possible and so on.
And here is the Mark of a good predictor and someone who likely isn't as
entertaining on TV,
a person who understands their assumptions about how they might possibly go
wrong. It's also why you should listen to data scientists about COVID numbers,
even after they allegedly changed their minds.
Even the current IMH prediction tool, which is publicly available,
lets you tweak for certain assumptions like the easing of lockdowns or
widespread mask usage.
A similar problem exists in media coverage of climate change scientists
constantly set forth scenarios that often range from best case to worst case
based on government policies or economic growth. For example,
while trying to iron out all the kinks of how our insanely complicated weather
system works. When these predictions are revised,
people often criticize them for being wrong.
Instead of lauding the scientists behind them for doing their job box wrote that
since all models are wrong,
the scientist must be alert to what is importantly wrong.
And whether you're making advanced computer models are just trying to give
better advice. The steps are the same.
You predict see the results and adjust the formula.
And therein lies the problem with people like crystal or whoever is giving you
pandemic hot takes on Twitter. There's no iterative process.
There's no accountability.
As Tetlock writes more often than not forecasts are made.
And then nothing accuracy is seldom determined after the fact every day,
the news media delivers forecasts without reporting or even asking how good the
forecasters who made the forecast really are.
So what should we do well for one avoid TV and maybe even
YouTube,
try to figure out when people are predicting for sport like on TV and if they
have any incentive at all to revise their bold proclamations when they're
incessantly wrong, most people don't.
And I would predict the world would be a much better place if we listened to
them a little less frequently. But what do I know? What do you guys think?
How can we ever know who to trust? Let us know in the comments. Huge,
thanks to our amazing patrons for your support,
decimate that subscribe button and as always, thanks for watching guys. Peace.
[Inaudible].